to help people to learn our language by
just talking
[Music]
hi there steve kaufman here now
what i'm doing now is a short
introduction to the video that i have
already made and which you're going to
see
where i talk about how i
enjoy listening to people talk
in the language that i'm learning and
listen to them over and over again
and i thought about the title for that
video and so i thought i should maybe
make this brief introduction
to justify the title the title i have is
talking our way to fluency
so
what do i mean by that i mean
other people talking to make me fluent
and i think what my video will talk
about in greater detail is this
tremendous opportunity we have
to help people to learn our language by
just talking so i can't talk my way to
fluency in persian
but if other people talk in persian and
record themselves that'll help me
achieve fluency if i keep listening to
it and even such things as my videos
here at youtube in fact are great
examples of me talking to help other
people achieve fluency
and i hope other people do the same
about themselves their lives what
interests them which in my case is
language learning but it might be music
it might be cooking it might be history
it might be sports
we can talk other people's way to
fluency so we can talk our way to
fluency as a collective effort i just
wanted to throw that in there to start
the video now on to the main video hi
there steve kaufman here
again to talk about language learning uh
if and today i want to talk about
this my experience with
people just talking about themselves
recording themselves and
being able to access this as language
learning material
if you like my videos please subscribe
you can
click or tap on the bell to get
notifications and by all means come and
join me at link to learn languages so
today was a cleanup day i spent a good
portion of the day
putting things away mess whatever
they're just an endless amount of things
to do to clean up
and for much of that time i was
listening to a series
to a course at link
called the iranians the iranians has
actually 46 lessons in it
uh
predominantly different people talking
about themselves
some of the lessons some of the these
monologues are followed by sort of
circling questions to help you know nail
down some of the vocabulary
those are the ones that are done by
sahara but there's a number of people in
there
people who
you know they're interested in music or
they're interested in food or they
they talk about yaldo yaldo which is uh
actually
yesterday or today is the uh the sort of
the the shortest day or the longest day
of the year i don't know which one but
sorry the shortest day or the when you
know the days start to get longer again
in other words it's around 20 the 21st
or 22nd of december
which is a very ancient
uh festival
uh
in
iran
joshua
and uh so
so there's all these stories 46 of them
as i'm listening to them and i just
checked my playlist because i what i
love to do is i just go to a course and
i say
you know play course audio and i shuffle
it and then i'll be for the if i'm
working around the house now for like
three four hours i'm just listening to
all these stories and i've listened to
some of them 10 times some of them four
times it shuffles it depends when we got
them into link
and of course the first few times i
listened i didn't didn't understand that
much now i understand a bit more still
lots of words that i don't know but i
become more and more familiar with the
phrases and the words and the
best
you know like a lot of their sort of
connecting phrases that they use
and uh and and you know it's it's just a
wonderful way to learn the language it's
so much more effective it's so much more
alive
than a
conventional textbook
and uh i can always look things up
grammar wise if i'm curious but i'm not
basically i just want to get used to
this how they how they use it and in in
per in a persian there's this sort of
formal way they speak and then the more
conversational way and of course these
are more conversational and so you start
to get used to them
because it's one thing to be told that
there's a more formal and a more
conversational but when you actually
hear people using this conversational
form
you start to get you know used to it
and it sort of dawned on me that
you know
uh
so many things have changed like
nowadays anyone with an iphone or a
android phone
can record something like this five six
seven minutes where they went to school
they changed their jobs the food they
like where they want to travel
whatever it might be it doesn't matter
you can even do uh you know a dialogue
uh except nowadays with covert that's
not such a good thing to do
uh however you can do it like what we
when i do my videos for skype typically
i use or for link for my for this
channel
typically what i do is i use zoom or
skype to connect with the person
but i look at my iphone they look at a
separate camera and then we merge the
audio and video files
but you could do that with pure audio as
well
so you could also create you know
dialogues
and so so that's there now the quality
of the audio is so much better than it
was
you know 10 15 years ago
and now
of course what's what's often
troublesome is to then transcribe your
five seven minute conversation or
monologue
but you can of course transcribe it or
you can get uh you know automatic
transcription and if you're a native
speaker and you have this automatically
transcribed
then you can quickly go in and correct
it and put in punctuation
uh we are looking at ways that we can
get more participation at link where
if people do put up
audio material maybe and uh maybe we'll
look at how we can get some of that
transcribed and whether native speakers
can help us fix them up a little bit and
put in punctuation the punctuation is
quite important because
if you can actually have sentences that
are actual sentences in sentence mode
rather than long paragraphs that is
sometimes the case then that makes
sentence mode even more
powerful um
you know as i've described i do that
with my uh my al jazeera podcasts i uh
where they're time stamps i can you know
relate the audio to the the sentence but
the sentence sentence is sometimes a
long paragraph which isn't all that
great but this idea of getting to know
people so you know i'm learning persian
so who are the iranians what do they
think about what are they interested in
what one person is interested in
different traditional iranian musical
instruments for example so you get to
know some of them even though you don't
know them you haven't met them but
you know learning about people
through the language
you know it's like it's a tremendous
sort of
intermediate type of content between our
many stories which have a tremendous
amount of repetition and which enable
you to go from literally nothing to
where you can understand some things
because it's there's just so much
repetition
now you go to something where it's a
little more interesting because you're
actually hearing
real people talk about their lives
but it's still relatively easy
as compared to say an article in a
newspaper
and yet you're learning about the people
so i think this is a great uh great way
to generate
learning material
i i hope people do more of it i want to
hear from people who want to do more of
it in their native language i think it's
a great way
to work to
you know maintain or or encourage people
to learn uh some of the lesser studied
languages or even threatened languages
or you know indigenous languages or
things of that nature because it's so
easy to create this you don't need
you know uh typically here in in canada
at any rate if they're gonna talk about
you know what are we gonna do to
preserve uh
native languages well some consultant
will be in there for a big fee trying to
build a big grammar book as if there
isn't one already and no one's going to
look at it anyway whereas really all you
need is to get people who speak the
language naturally to just record
themselves
talking about things that matter to them
and then to somehow get that transcribed
and then make that available for people
to use and as long as there's online
dictionaries
we are
ready to roll so i just wanted to
comment on how much i enjoyed my day
getting to know these people
in this course we have called the
iranians and it sort of fills out my
understanding of iran i have the the
history series that sahara created i
have
we had a
she put up a lesson on iranian bred she
has one on iranian food she has one on
ethnic groups in iran
uh
and
and history of course and now i have the
iranians talking about themselves so it
just fills that whole picture in and as
you're listening and learning about
these people
uh you're learning the language so
that's kind of
where you know language learning is
going
thanks for listening bye for now and
merry christmas and happy yaldo whatever
they say in the iranian i don't know in
person
and uh
yeah we will uh
we'll be talking again bye for now
[Music]